and control meeting for the development
be committee mayor first of all remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones we'll turn them to
silent I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the Internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may record film photographed or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn it off when you've
finished now move on to the
introductions and on my right I have in
Despres our legal officer John pate
Minji our appeal planning manager myself
Kathy Guthrie I'm the chair today we
have Robert Carmichael who's our
governance officer we then have Jack
Wilson planning officer and our very
able IT expert we also have members more
members of our officers up here who will
present we also have I see a highways
expert with us here today thank you very
much
we have down here
members of the ward representatives who
will speak on behalf of the community we
have the planning committee who will
debate and vote on the applications
before us and in the audience behind us
we have applicants agents members of the
public and people who've hopefully
mentioned that they would like their
three minutes to speak everybody's
entitled to three minutes to speaker
supporter objector Parish Council the
applicant and of course our Ward members
get a little longer so let's move on to
the agenda please do we have apologies
for absence and substitutions none
receive chair to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
declarations of lobbying and for me that
would be on the first application and
also the the bill distant and the often
and the sunshine one for me is that the
same for all of you any other lobbying
yes thank you declarations of personal
site visits councillor Matheson
just a declaration of a personal site
visit thank you
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting health on the 4th of September
and I look from page 1 through to page
13 and unless there are any amendments
if you would like to point them out to
me
are you happy that I sign these minutes
sign them
thank you very much I'll do that during
the course of the meeting thank you very
much to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
counselors petition scheme none receive
chair but just to note that there was a
petition associated with the first one
that was the first item before committee
that was reported the last time that he
came to our committee previously thank
you very much and the sheduled of the
planning applications will be the order
in which they are in your papers today
so without further ado may we move on to
the page 5 and Jack if you'd like to
make the presentation of the case please
thank you very much
thank you madam chair good morning
members members of the public I'm Jack
Wilkinson principal planning officer in
the Durham service for Behram at Suffolk
District Council the first item is as
per your papers its land southwest of
Maine Road summer shrim proposal is for
42 dwellings together with associated
public open space access garage Inge car
parking and this is a twin track
application there's a duplicate of this
item members you may recall that you
wanted to excite visit on 3rd of July
and the item was subsequently presented
to you on the 10th of July but the item
was deferred seeking highways resolution
so in terms of vacation I will skip
through most of these slides again we
have already been through this we will
come on to the main points in a second
but just to refresh your memory in terms
of a site it's a 1.8 - hectare site on
the edge of settlement of a primary
village the redline outline has shown
the site is largely unconstrained
however there are a few features nearby
that are relevant in what is ultimately
your material consideration we have
listed building to the north in the form
of the JQ barber pub we have the cottage
here on the corner which is also listed
with a public right-of-way which runs
along the south of the site and which
links off as you can see by the green
mark here in terms of the aerial view at
the minute this is open paddock land the
land does sloped gently from the west to
the east towards main road at the minute
the site is served by an internal road
this would be ultimately beefed up in
any future planning application approval
when I'll come on to the access in a
moment in terms of links we've discussed
about this church the pub community shop
and primary school
as you can see the site outlined in red
so this is a full plans planning
application with all details key
features being the main internal road in
the secondary road linking off
independent driveway serving units and
public open space which is a welcome
benefit there's also quite an integral
landscaping component of forming part of
this application the existing access as
shown facing north facing south into the
bulk of the village you know opposite
the site is an established footpath we
did stand at this point during our site
visit and into the detail with regards
to the access there is display provision
set in both the left and right facing
visibility splays and I set a two point
four meter setback this is above and
beyond the Highways requirements so
following deferral last time we did go
back and consult the local hives
authority and we did indeed discuss this
with the developer there's an amendment
come through which does show the extent
to which the footpath provision is
provided so if I go back to forgive me
the previous slide you'll see that the
footpath provision continues around to
the left but it stops around to the
right
this is an effect to be rerouted so
you'll see the footpath provision stops
at this corner now occupants would have
the option of using the footpath over
the road as existing in terms of the
actual width of the access this is
acceptable in terms of the visibility in
both ways as I've said but also the
functionality of the access to serve 42
units extending into site as I've
mentioned we have primary layout
secondary and third way driveways we
also have an opening towards the
southern boundary whereby if residents I
wish they could access the public
right-of-way which runs along the south
of the site this is a welcome benefit I
feel this drawing is quite important in
terms of an understanding of how the
site links to the footpath provision now
as I've mentioned quite a few times the
public right-of-way runs along the south
we also have access through the site to
this point along opposite site and also
a detail here which I'll discuss in a
moment in detail that is a benefit to
this game it's not fundamental but it is
a benefit to this game in terms of how
the site links to the remainder of the
village towards the south so members may
recall what may be described as a pinch
point which is towards the south east
outside the red line but nonetheless
secured by way of section 106 agreement
that would be improved now at the minute
I think it's fair to say that we have no
provision along this stretch now
officers are of the sound opinion that
this is acceptable in terms of whether
the site is connected to the remainder
of the village and whether you could
reasonably walk this has been revised
and has come through again with a one
meter wide foot way so residents would
have the option via the yellow marked
area
to walk from site via the public
right-of-way round
and connect to the rest of the village
in terms of actual improvement there
would be dragon teeth marks which would
slow traffic towards this point they
would be fresh printing along the
junction along with clear markings that
would depict the foot way which we have
been working hard on in terms of the
actual width it's a 3.5 meter width this
is acceptable and this has been
rigorously tested and assessed by your
local highways engineers this is the
public open space which I've already
spoken about I don't think it's
necessary to delve too deeply into the
remainder of the matters that we
discussed last time out as it was
principally a highways deferral
so I will skip through these images
which are going show the site as
existing I'll be happy to go back to
these should you require me to do so
the landscaping layout would be bound
along with all conditions hedgerow
condition as well and these are the
proposed elevations
it's quite a good mix and blend in terms
of what it is that it's proposed you've
got good brick details you've got good
tile details along with all the
integrated garage features that would
form either way of the dwellings so the
existing site as you may recall
so just to summarize this is a 42
dwelling scheme bound by section 106 for
35% affordable housing and it's an
acceptable density good public open
space car park provision along with
cyber spaces there are links as we've
discussed and the provision in terms of
highways and the footpath availability
is above and beyond what the local high
authority deem necessary it's a
fundamental aspect of how we as officers
consider it and I trust that those
material considerations are before you
to enable you to make a decision on that
basis your recommendation subject to the
106 and the draft headers is for
approval thank you just before we go to
questions and John is just going to yes
thank you just in respect of your
recommendation just for the avoidance of
doubt we will be expecting a condition
on the footworks to the pinch point as
it's been referred to and protection
also to be agreed and sort of secured
and details to be agreed to the
overhanging building looks on that
corner of that point so there are
details there that we need to secure we
have obviously some of those details
already with us but in order for us to
look at those and make sure that they
are absolutely the finer details of
those are absolutely correct and that
that is a condition that is part of your
recommendation thank you so before we go
to questions of the officer we have
obviously been through this presentation
before matters have changed we do have
the Highways Authority representative
here today but if you can keep your
questioning to the application on things
that you might not be clear on or that
you haven't heard so do we have any
further questions bearing in mind we
also have the ward member to speak the
and any objectives so any questions yes
counselor Mathison thank you yes on
paragraph 7.4 the sustainability
officers objection has there been any
further engagement which might have
reduced that particular concern in terms
of engagement with the sustainability
officer we did talk with the officer who
was invited no longer in post and we
have spoken with the developer on
various improvement measures that could
come through in any perspective build
now there has been a sustainability
stipend included that will be part of
the approved plans
I think we're fairly limited in what we
can hinge for but nonetheless that has
been considered yes yes please
well it's questions for the officer of
something that I mean I'm not going to
have Sam present a separate case you've
got the the debate to come forward and
people to represent so for the officer
you know No yeah okay counselor Mathison
yeah could we could you explain exactly
what an informal priority system what
that exactly means please just explain
it would you do that for us please if
it's in this case thank you sorry we're
just waiting for Internet
Thank You counsel the informal priority
system is at present very similar to
what it is now the informal priority
system we have originally the original
design that came forward was a formal
priority system but this will be decided
when we come to the detailed design for
the scheme when it comes to under the
section 2 7 8 of the Highways Act yes I
mean I I'm fortunately I I only officer
didn't actually look at that on my
private site visit a solid you ask the
question arrow what have you got as an
arrow saying the priority this way or
that way so that vehicles know what to
do with in an informal priority system
it's basically a give take as in its its
confidant have any arrows or anything
else as existing at the moment there is
an informal priority system at the
moment Thank You counsel okay thank you
it's just a question regarding one of
the parts the information we requested
at last meeting that was regarding the
accident in 2016 not be killed on a
crash map when if you've got an update
of that and also the outcome of it thank
you the we have no information of an
accident back in 2016 I'm afraid any
further questions for the opposite yes
counselor Carter thank you
regarding Lee footpath I was just erm do
we take in consideration the average
width of a motorized wheelchair and
average which were width of a bush foot
pram pram we do the manufa streets
document says for wheelchairs of one
meter wide foot way is allowable for a
short duration this as we know that one
means
isn't our ideal specification but it is
wide enough for a wheelchair and for a
buggy but it's not wide enough for two
people to pass but this was considered
that the amount of pedestrian traffic
they'll be using it and for a short
section this will be sufficient thank
you
yes one further question just regarding
if we did happen to have a motorized
wheelchair which is about 36 inches wide
and a buggy which on average is about 37
inches wide which of the two is likely
to have to step down from the curb in in
front of a traffic I think that's a bit
of an unfair question to the officer but
your point is raised and we can use that
in debate would that be satisfactory for
you counselor Thank You councillor wall
boys
could you put your microphone on please
yes thank you pie there has been a
traffic survey done at peak time and
there's just over 200 vehicles traveling
along that road at peak time there's I
did send the indication whether this is
a tidal flow whether the majority of the
traffic was flowing in one direction say
in the morning and then the opposite
direction in the evening I was serving
from what said that the traffic is going
both ways so wouldn't a firkin further
constriction on this pinch point
actually increase the chances of traffic
building up in other direction okay and
the title is if it was about 300 it's
150 vehicles each way we I haven't got
the information in front of me I'm
afraid but when I've been on site in the
peak hour I've only seen about three
cars may be waiting at that pinch point
before the other cars gone past that is
my own personal one on the day that I
was there at the peak hour I'm afraid I
can't tell you if there was any other
congestion we didn't ask the transport
assessment for the queue lengths because
it wasn't being necessary at the time
councilor Norris castle wall boy so
you've finished your questioning I mean
their question we're not debating we're
questioning
yes not not quite because there's that's
the current situation if this
development were to carry out there be
further traffic on that road I think
this substance is 42 houses so they
could well be 42 extra vehicles on that
road as the design taken into account
extra number of vehicles guard to trip
rates trip rates for this scheme for 42
dwellings we times that five point six
because it's our a rural community so
therefore it's about you estimate or it
is considered that there will be
approximately twenty six trip rates in
the peak hour period which will be one
every two minutes so that isn't
considered a huge amount for this area
Thank You Council Norris and then
counselor field and anyone else that I
haven't caught my eye
thank you yes going back to what's
referred to as an informal traffic
priority system is it intended to have
any signs indicating who has a priority
or a sign such as one sees about
oncoming traffic in the middle of the
road or similar yes at present there we
are science saying traffic oncoming the
middle of the road there is a informal
transistor there at present as I said
before when we get to the section two
seven eight of the agreement agreement
with the developer for the footway works
it will be safety audited and the safety
audit will pick up anything that they
deem necessary to change the design but
the previous one what our previous
design was a priority system and the
safety orders are deemed that at present
the informal priority system works very
well so not to put the priority system
in councilor field thank you
thank you two or three questions on
which I'm one at the time first of all
the officer pointed to an established
footpath on the opposite side of the
main road to the development wonder if
you could point out where that footpath
ceases
thank you for your question so in terms
of the footpath opposite the site so an
elevated position over the road it
finishes in this approximate position
here as marked no it's in an elevated
position only marginally from the road I
think there's a small verge
approximately two feet that's elevated
from the actual bound carriageway quite
good for wheelchairs and things then and
it stops do you know how far short of
the pinch point that stops I think we're
looking Misaka eight metres when we're
on site actually slopes off either end I
think you know further up towards Duke
of Marlborough you have flatter lower
lying Vick Euler Highway and indeed
pedestrian highway so you looking for
the distance from it to the pinch point
and it passes at least three buildings
so eight meters sounds a bit short to me
right I am measuring the the end of the
footpath on the opposite side of the
road to the site here to well when he
say pinch point it's an argument away
that starts but let's say to the net
building that overhangs that's about 40
meters thank you
bearing in mind we obviously have the
public footpath on the opposite side of
the road and this and the point of this
development is its burden on the area
not the existing situation so now the
approach is available for the existing
properties added the new properties the
suggestion was people had an option of
crossing to that footpath and using it
merely making sure counselors are aware
of the constraints on such ease the
second thing was the you mentioned the
public right-of-way which exists along
the edge of the allotments at this lower
edge of the side I wonder if the officer
could explain what the characteristics
of that right of why are is it is it
flat or is it sloping is it surfaced or
is it unsurfaced so the public
right-of-way is typical of the
countryside location it's a varying mix
in terms of grass areas gravel and
indeed mudded areas I think I've got a
photo here so I will that's towards the
south facing west with the site on the
right-hand side you can see the fencing
looking into side
and this would be down towards the south
eastern corner along the public
rights-of-way which I hope gives an idea
of what is here but you don't have a bit
a picture of it from my road the this
the steepness of the slope I I don't I'm
afraid no thank you the next issue would
be to me the nature of the area you
described as a yellow marked area that
proposed foot why Harry that constructed
that that would be decided when it comes
to see a number of options where it
could be just a colored surface it could
be a 50ml high which is two inches high
curve face it could have 18 mile curve
face it's something when it gets to
detailed design it will be decided at
that point but there are a number of
options that we could choose at the
moment I do believe that showing 50ml
curve faces a two inch drop
but there have been some ideas as I said
floating around the office as into what
it could be constructed of thank you
thank you cancel afield thank you you
you oh I thought you only had three
questions sorry can you put your
microphone on yes it was the the width
of the road at the moment we were
talking about you were explaining an
informal priority system I understand
the road is to be three-and-a-half
meters wide is that adequate to support
two-way direction traffic and is it
currently supporting two-way traffic at
the present time there is sufficient
room for two cars to pass there isn't
sufficient room for a car and a lorry to
pass so this is when there's the
informal priority where we are
suggesting to put the foot way it will
narrow it down to a single carriageway
will be a definite there is no room for
two cars to pass a lorry can pass three
and a half meters
the only thing would be difficult would
be for a combine to pass three and a
half meters but there they will be able
to overhang foot way I don't know come
go through there now but at the present
time there are two there's enough room
for two cars to pass but at a squeeze so
by reducing it down and we just sewn
into one car and there Laurie can pass
through okay
could you just explain to me how an
informal priority system works when a
driver at one end of such system cannot
see the vehicle the opposing end at
present it's working very well at
present people can see you cannot see
the informal priority system there are a
number across Suffolk County as as we
said before when it comes to section two
seven eight in agreement we will decide
or will it would be safe to audited out
and we will have a look at if a priority
system should be introduced into the
area thank you I mean I don't want to
sort of labor the point all on highways
but how many questions have you got
because it is unusual for board members
to sort of take over the meeting but I'm
prepared to let you keep going because
it's very interesting unusual I guess I
was merely trying to ensure there are
people opposite understand the situation
fully I did have one other question
perhaps the MPP F states that something
should be rejected on highways ground if
there would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety just ask the officers
professional opinion on that point
all the information that was provided by
the applicant showed that there isn't a
severe Aang in pact on highway safety
there is an alternative route for the
pedestrian for them to be able to make
to the village with the public
rights-of-way would point out there is
another alternative room there is a
public right-of-way but it ceases but
that's the very top so if I may just add
a couple of things in respect to those
questions
the firstly you mentioned the surfacing
of the public right-of-way on page 24 of
the report you will see that part of
this proposal does include surface
improvement works to the public
rights-of-way and that would effectively
upgrade those paths to be more suitable
for various users I would also just
mention that we are the local planning
authority we are not the Highways
Authority we have to there is a certain
limit limit of what we can do before we
do have to trust the different authority
with its own responsibilities
needs to consider the finer details and
we can't design a highway scheme we
don't have the experts to do so but I
will leave it there before I go too much
further right
councillor canter is this a question
we're not in to debate yet we haven't
had all the presentations from people
that available at 1 it should a combine
be coming through and overhanging a path
the path being utilized at a time by a
motorized wheelchair without the
possibility of crossing over and without
the possibility of moving out away who
has right away in who has to move back
would combine after reverse out lathe
would be wheelchair to get across the
road now about the distance or what
would happen now the I would imagine I
would hope that a combine harvester
driver would be considerate of the
pedestrian and somebody maybe in a
wheelchair a motorized roto there they
I've met many a combines I think I think
I think John just wants to add a little
extra to that to thank you I think it's
very clear to everybody must be quite
frank about this this is not the perfect
road it is not wide enough to meet every
modern day standards or particular types
of vehicles there are issues in respect
to this road the issue before us in
terms of a planning application is
whether this application and the nature
of traffic likely to be associated with
it in the long term would be so
detrimental and so severe and its impact
to warrant refusal so I would caution
exploring the existing situation to the
M fatigue array I would be careful in
your balance of what is reasonable
and day by day thank you now has anyone
any further questions for the officer
thank you very much and so we now move
on if we may please and we have the
parish can't
James Caston things
thank you madam chairman
so the parish councils discussed this
application and also discussed the
proposed road layout I'd like to UM
firstly go through quickly the some of
the issues and then talk about this main
issue of the pinch point on the road say
well the residents have drawn attention
to an issue of a sewer pipe is
frequently blocks running down from the
site the the visuals blades the Duke of
Marlborough we consider to be inadequate
the traffic statement evidences gap was
gathered between 700 and 800 and 1600
and 1700 we have information from our
Road Safety adviser that we find that to
be inaccurate and peak times
Oh 730 - Oh a 45 and similar in the
evening the the houses on stocks Hill
had no foundation and any building here
would have - the builders would have to
take special measures to protect them
but the major issue we have is with this
pump house corner the pinch point the
parish council looked at the proposed
changes to the road layer and
unanimously agreed they not only
wouldn't solve the problem they would
increase the risk the footpath actually
moves vehicles over to the inside of the
corner reducing the point at which they
see each other we consider 3.5 meters as
being unsafe for lorries and
agricultural equipment that quite often
carry a three meter wide implement on
the back they would have to cut the bend
to avoid the overhanging houses on the
other side it is not safe in this form
also the footpaths and stocks Hill the
what counts the field was talking about
the the entry onto the road I wouldn't
be a
push my mother-in-law's wheelchair up
that hill and I'm fairly physically
strong in my 30s earned a farmer I just
couldn't do it
so I'm the the only way this can be made
safer is to run straight in the road to
increase the visibility the the road is
that road is dangerous and by developing
this area we are pretty much locking the
door and throwing away the key on any
improvement ever to be made to that
corner this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity to not build on the part
where the road could be straightened and
the rope that could be made safer so
well yeah thank you very much I'm happy
to take any questions thank you very
much for the input thank you thank you
madam Jim we now move on to mr. Andrew
Lachlan please and if you'd like to come
along and present your case thank you
all right thank you for let me speak
we've got a couple images which will be
shown as and what we've referred to in
this in this comment so I will continue
Suffolk County Council highways does not
consider the impact of introducing a 1
meter foot wave as being a severe risk
in fact they can see it consider it to
be a betterment but to reach that
conclusion they have refused to consider
the impact of anything other than
off-peak traffic flow and have relied on
so-called professional opinion and
unreliable statistics no one within the
authority has been prepared to give
credence to practical local knowledge to
date all Road assessments have been
during off-peak time the Suffolk County
Council highways review the road safety
audit and even the committee's on-site
review have all taken place late morning
no one has assessed the risk during peak
time traffic flows when 220 plus
vehicles passed through the stops hill
main road section of Mill Lane why has
there been an irrational reluctance to
do this because the cumulative impact
would then come into play and it will be
impossible to suggest that the impact of
a footway proposal is anything but
severe we'll take a look at the images
image one this woman is moved moving
through the section where the footway is
proposed to be she's also taste
interrupts just before we start we just
to explain to members we're only going
to have two photographs that you're
going to put up so if members could look
at them we'd be grateful thank you I'm
stopped o'clock thank you very much way
up it was there I'll give you the
longest side thank you
image image one this woman is moving
through the section where the foot was
proposed to be she's also taking a
chopped-up if she was taking a child to
school would you expect the child or the
pushchair to be next to the traffic when
when that's our where would the mother
and child retreat to when the arriving
cars seek to avoid a collision who's the
most expendable because somebody will
need to be
[Applause]
sorry wasting my time I had an image too
but I'm not showing it but but this has
a cyclist moving at speed
if you imagine use your imagination to
consider entremet oncoming vehicles are
now traveling in the 3.5 meter route the
cyclist won't see see the vehicle does
the severe side to survive unscathed
probably not images 3 & 4 will show you
just one of those images large vehicles
must also use the full width of the road
to negotiate the pinch point there are
daily near misses we accept the reported
accidents are low but a 3.5 metre
roadway will turn those near misses into
accidents reported accidents to date are
not a reflection of the true dangers
near misses haven't even been considered
a main road is not a rural road why
because off-peak service surveys will
not pick up the severity of this but
they will allow planning policy and NPP
F paragraphs to be favorably interpreted
perhaps we're being naive but surely
planning policy and MPP F paragraphs are
there to ensure due diligence in the
process and that at least the outcome
upholds public and property safety we
can only conclude that the sanitized
assessment is designed to support an
underlying agenda to approve this
development at all costs otherwise why
has there been dissent unreasonable and
irrational reluctance to be thorough we
feel that both District Planning and
County highways by not diligently
challenging the proposal are
irresponsibly risking the safety of the
residents of summer ship and surrounding
villages and to be frank no one in the
authority seems to care
so in conclusion some of highways
consider this to be a betterment how can
it be an improvement
when pedestrians and cyclists will be
put at risk of being run over it doesn't
offer inclusive access the risk of
vehicle head-on sideswiped collisions
and collisions with heritage assets will
increase yes
residents will be placed in danger when
leaving home the visibility of oncoming
traffic will further be would be further
reduced where was the due diligence in
the process where is the balance
view of risk where's the betterment so
on the grounds on those grounds we ask
this planning application is refused
thank you thank you for that I will ask
members if they do have any questions I
have a question for you I'm very well
aware of the passion and the involvement
that you have in this case and I've read
every email that's come in on it maybe
from yourself has your property been hit
yes over the last how many years because
I've been there twice it's been hit it
was hit unfortunately by James's father
in his one of his vehicles when I first
moved into the into the property it was
hit again after that but since then it
hasn't been hit but it's come very close
what tell a lie we have had it scraped
by a bus
what on the the sections are overhangs
the road so they've got very very close
and I'm sure you've read the report very
thoroughly as as we all have and there
is an item there and it alludes to the
highways things and you have to
understand that the Planning Committee
relies on the highways telling us and
there is an area for section two seven
eight to be engaged with the developer
and yourself have you read that bit
error earlier that bit of the report and
are you aware that if that fails then no
matter what the decision of this
committee is it would also fail at that
point are you aware of that
no I was well I just like to point that
okay I was aware that it was it was
there but my concern was that it came
after the approval stage it is something
to that it depends how the committee
vote on this but it is something that
the committee would give the planning
officer the authority to deal with and
if it fails at that point of my correct
John that that would
yeah ultimately if something fundamental
comes out of the section t78 the
Highways Authority had the power to to
stop that work you know not allow it to
go ahead what I'm keen on is making sure
there's a connection between that and
the development itself not going ahead
regardless of that so my advice to
members I mentioned earlier that we
would obviously need to secure the
footway works and the protection to the
the pomp cottage building I would
actually propose to members that that is
all sealed and agreed and the sexual
section t78 is sorted prior to
commencement of the building if members
wanted to in order to ensure that that
development goes no further subject to
the highway works I had got it down as
prior to occupation because it's
normally the use of the buildings that
cause the burden of the development but
in this case I see no reason why we
can't make it prior to commencement it
does mean that we would have to seek
agreement from the applicant for that
condition because he's a prior to
commencement condition but we can do
that if that's where members go in the
debate and can you turn your microphone
off but I use it as a question to get
the point forward okay thank you you're
now aware of it of course thank you and
yes counselor Humphries
I'm sure thank you two questions first
question is timing of the traffic
contradicts what the counselor said you
sit still late morning the counselor
said we were done between 7 and 0 800
which is correct the the peak time
traffic is as as james's mentioned it's
between 7:30 and 8:45 the assessments
have been late morning so they saw the
on-site assessment to actually witness
the traffic have been blame Ordnung
do I think it's to between zero seven
zero eight hundred as state body part
that's my opinion
can i second question could I just
clarify my second question is its
roaming in a baby would you not actually
conclude just to give balance to your
point that if there was a footpath there
they would be safer no because the foot
part so the footpath is at the moment is
proposed as a painted line it's not
anyone mentioned that is if it was a two
inch up stand it will become even more
of a hazard because the vehicles were
there might be mounting it and we saw
what happened in 2016 when the vehicle
hit the curb and turned over its aged
thank you any further christen council
war boys and can you all just remember
to switch on and off because we can't
get doesn't just a couple of questions
your buildings a listed building isn't
it it's a great - and it's a jetted
building understand
so the second-story projects how far
approximately 400 millimeters about half
a meter okay thank you very much I mean
just I think to avoid them
misunderstanding if I just the exchange
between the vice-chairman and this
speaker with the speaker was saying that
he he he agrees with mr. Casten I'm
calling James mr. Casten because
although he's one of our district
councillors he's not here in that
capacity today and he's a parish
councillor yet and the the parish
councils
you're saying you agree with the
carriage council statement as to when
the peak time for traffic is which is
7:00 a.m. to 8:45 did I get that right I
didn't write it down
and your concern and your criticism is
that you do not believe that the
assessments have been made with
reference to data at that time is that
right so that was that was the you're
you're worried about being misunderstood
better just go back to that right where
are we any further no if you'd like to
return to your seat thank you very much
indeed thank you and we don't have have
a supporter and we now have the
applicant or the agent mr. Chris Smith
please I'll just just before please do
come down but just before you do there
is a comment or just I think mr. mr.
payment Jesus just drawing my attention
that we III wanted to make sure that the
speaker hadn't been misunderstood and
I've done that but I think the points
being made to me that there is the
County Council are saying they have in
writing that they have done it and that
was may have been councilor Humphries
just pulling members attention to page
83 of your papers I'll let you read that
to understand it in that respect but
they reviewed the truck transport
assessment and that is in respect of
a.m. peak times being taken into account
10:00 p.m. peak times just that's new
they have a system thank you if you've
no like to have your three minutes thank
you very much thank you madam chair
councillors my name's Chris Smith on
development planner for Hopkins and more
following the previous deferral at the
July committee as you have heard and as
requested by yourselves we met with the
offices of Suffolk County Council
highways on-site at the end of July
walked the route concerned and agreed
through a series of drawings the
proposals that are now in front of you
in which we sent to you along with the
layout plan ahead of this committee
meeting as you've heard those details
have been agreed in principle with
offices as the best possible
compromise in this situation to enable
improve pedestrian linkages from the
west of the site to the east for the
benefit of both existing and future
residents and at the same time seek to
slow the traffic and control the traffic
as as best as possible in the situation
to avoid incidents and indeed improve
the situation over what currently exists
so on that basis given that you have
previously comfortable with the
remainder of the proposals we trust that
you are able to concur with the offices
recommendation and support the proposals
that's all I really want to say but as
always I'm happy to answer any questions
any questions don't appear - thank you
very much indeed
now we come on to Council of field as
board member please thank you thank you
first of all perhaps apologize I didn't
put a written submission until yesterday
so councillors may not have had quite
enough talent to read that no one was
really struggling for something really
constructive to say about the process I
think after the last meeting which the
application was deferred for further
work on safety issues I expected
evidence of significant effort and clear
application of highways engineering
skill a further new proposal was for far
short of those needed to persuade the
community that the development is
acceptable and to ensure that the
requirements of the MPP F are met
particularly those requirements are the
ones that state application should be
refused on highways grounds if there is
will be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety that goes on to say or
the residual cumulative impact on the
road network will be severe
I feel the judgments been
the second criteria of those two but the
first relating to safety appears to
being given little white it appears to
me also that there's been no engagement
with the community and I was emails that
were seen appear to state that there's
no resource to accomplish that
despite the value of this development it
clearly will would have had
substantially to the local economy to go
on to the current proposal or say you
have before you were a proposal to put a
foot way on the right-of-way in place a
foot way on on the right-of-way in place
together with a pointed foot way on
stops hillside of mine Road and an
informal one-way system
residents are not impressed with that
the foot was on a steep rise at the main
road end and appears to be on private
land not under the applicants control
the on one foot way their shared space I
guess is as County highways point out
narrow but it's minor e issue is that
pedestrians are unprotected paint on the
road provides a little security physical
curves will be preferable but it's
difficult are difficult to place as they
would compromise Road use by large
vehicles I think I did provide a couple
of pictures of large vehicles in that at
that position the foot weighs thirty
metres long it would take about twenty
two and a half seconds for a fit
pedestrian I'm impeded by a child or any
mobility difficulties to pass that
length if they set off in a gap in the
traffic which they could see at best
some 220 meters away a vehicle at 30
miles an hour would travel 300 meters
towards them somewhat bigger than the
difference I've got
the footway place that proposed would
also move traffic towards and listening
buildings which have a name overhang
which is known to be vulnerable
it would appear more appropriate that if
the football on the Kings Cottage side
as though it would move traffic away and
protect the overhang the one-way system
is informal as drivers entering either
end those with priority or not would not
be able to see vehicle entering from the
opposite end I found it difficult to see
how we might imagine that that would
work so there you know it clearly at the
moment for large vehicles it works large
vehicles are clearly moving very slowly
and there is a form of refuge between
the two listed buildings in which
vehicles of some size that can can
escape I guess other wall has it's just
a matter of hoping that random events
that occurrence of two large vehicles at
the same place at the same time are
fairly unlikely my feeling is that some
form of signaling between the aims of
living fully operational priority system
would be essential traffic control
lights would appear to be a solution
although they're not acceptable normally
in a rural village this analysis is just
to me that there would be an
unacceptable impact on highway safety
were the development to go ahead with
the highways measures as they are
currently defined I'm reluctant to
pariah through house improvements as are
not a highways engineer however the
parish believed a minor realignment to
mine Road on the development side of
Kings cottage and placement of foot by
on the Kings cottage saw the road would
allow the vehicle into visibility and
the priority one way system to be
implemented safely that would allow
residents of the development to obtain
to abduct sustainable modes of train
sport and I think he's the prom issue
we're considering at the moment at the
meeting if the meeting is determined to
proceed with the current highways design
then at minimum a 20 mile per hour zone
should be put in place to improve
pedestrian chance of survival if or when
an accident occurs so my conclusion is
the businesses application do not
address adequately the issues of the
unacceptable impact on highway safety
that arise from the need for pedestrian
traffic from the proposed development to
transit the section of mine road in
front of Kings cottage in the pump house
therefore I feel with this application
it should be rejected at least until the
highways issues are resolved
thank you for that council failed we
will go to questions you've made some
interesting points that I've actually
raised myself but I think it made it
quite clear we are not the Highways
Authority and that is where we've got to
consider our debate today but thank you
for sending us the paper copy and thank
you for your information earlier so does
anyone have any further questions of the
ward member cancer Richardson thank
you've got a couple of questions about
the existing village firstly do you have
a rough approximation how many people
live in sumption second you had two
people or pedestrians in particular
currently transit between the western
half of the village by the Duke of
Marlborough pub and the eastern half
with the shop and the primary school
high on the district counts the arrow I
regret to say I don't know exactly how
many people are in the village aye aye
aye I believe it's around 700 but I
would be happy if the parish council
corrected me on that clearly at the
moment the people who live at the Duke
of Marlborough end of the village walk
through the existing
pinch point to the to the physician
recommendation ground the school the
village hall the the village shop
clearly that's what they do currently as
far as I'm aware they walk on the Kings
cottage side of the band and you can
certainly take refuge between Kings
cottage in the Palmer House in a
slightly wider area of the road at that
point so at the moment they take the
risk they don't have any choice any
further questions I just have one take
the highways out of things generally is
the application in your view and
acceptable one there's a parish council
meeting tonight I might say I'd rather
I'd rather not answer that but the
obvious truthful answers village is
always object to increases in housing it
changes their environment I do tend to
believe it's in an appropriate place and
appears to be reasonably well laid out
so yeah I'm not personally averse to the
development it's really just this impact
of exactly writing I know my outstanding
safety issue considerable risk to new
people who will be moving in who would
wish to adopt sustainable transport
modes to some facilities clearly they're
going to drive to it which will catch
the bus that is for those who died but
you know there are things locally which
they wish to do and which I've seen
people doing so increase to that it to
me is unacceptable and one final
question what's been going on in the
past and to improve what you perceive is
the current and many others do as the
current issues what has been going on
with the district councillor there I've
only been district councillor since my
so no
don't deal I'm fully aware that the
previous County counselor spent a
considerable time on this issue looking
at issues like vehicle activated signs
you know changes to run configuration
whatever and to my knowledge must have
spent years trying to get some movement
but there's always an issue of we're
we're offsetting and known impact on
someone's budget against a risk of an
accident and one final question and are
you aware of the situation that arose at
Woolpit with exactly the same i am yep
thank you thank you very much so we now
move on to debate so whoever wants to
start you're most welcome
counselor Gould thank you so much it
some of what I say is a kind of by way
of a reminder to myself as a new council
need you to the planning committee and
what it is that we can consider and what
it is we we have to put to one side
clearly
regarding this application are matters
of concern relation to the highway prior
prior to pre-existing this application I
minded also about the point that's being
made a couple of times that we are
necessarily improperly reliant on the
advice of the Highways Authority in in
coming to judgment so looking at this
development in its own terms as it were
it seems to me to be an appropriate
development that the relationship
between the development and the and the
highway through the through the spray
and the access which I understand the
officer to say
and exceeds minimum requirements is is
is to be welcome
much has been said questions asked in
relation to informal traffic control
measures it's a shame that the highways
officer has has has left us but I
understand it to be the case that there
is a trend in highways policy towards
informal arrangements and away from
highly controlled because it the the
evidence is that this puts more
responsibility on the driver and
behavior is improved in that students
reduced I I don't have the authority for
that this is my understanding from what
from what I've read CATSA field makes a
proposal in relation this goes ahead in
relation to a 20 mile per hour so I
understand that the Highways Authority
is moving away from the introduction of
20 mile per hour so I have to within my
ward one in Auckland which has been
there for some time and and the abuse of
which dominates each parish council
agenda it's not there's no enforcement
associated with it it seems to make no
difference whatsoever to actual Road
discipline and we've just had one
introduced in I I have to say the
experiences are saying those that he'd
traffic diligent drivers remain diligent
those who weren't are unaffected it
seems by the by the presence of 20 mile
per hour zone so I'm not sure that that
would improve matters at all so I it
seems to me that this that this proposal
is is a reasonable proposal and I'm not
sure so about caps afield statement that
villages always object to
to development certainly I don't think
that's a universal truth and isn't true
in my award thank you very much thank
you
well I was just going to say to remind
members that it depends how the debate
goes of course that the condition to put
section two seven eight be acceptable
before any commencement would be a
condition that could be included as the
debate goes forward counselor gaudiya
yes so that was going to be one of my
points which I have which I admitted to
mention there that was a that I would
wish to see that as a as condition prior
to commencement that's very helpful
thank you right who else would like to
speak please councillor Norris thank you
I know you want to support this
application for these reasons appears to
me there is a lack of safe connectivity
of the proposed development to local
facilities particularly with regard to
the proposal to construct the one meet a
wide foot between the public
right-of-way and D footwork foot way
network for joining a single carriageway
with the width of only three point five
meters requiring what is referred to as
an informal traffic priority system
proposed book-y of only one metre wide
is not to suffer design standard at one
point eight meters width in spite of
what has been said about the highways
aspects I still have considerable
concerns regarding public safety some
some parish councils comments on page
seven included a statement and that in
their opinion was the present main road
configuration is unsafe at the pinch
point adjacent to Keim's Cottage Street
farm and the old post office what is
being proposed would Mike the situation
significantly worse
this view is supported within the many
objections from residents detailed on
pages 9 and 10 and a petition against
the proposed application with a hundred
and sixty four signatures an email
received from an objector includes the
comment that the public right-of-way
from the proposed development to stops
hill narrows to a single track rough
walkway unsuitable for anyone other than
able-bodied pedestrians as regards
sustainability and Environmental House
have responded on page nine with an
objection stating that the proposal is
too vague in its commentary around the
state sustainability benefits provided
in relation to new build and for these
reasons I cannot support this
application thank you thank you for that
counseling Matheson thank you
yeah this is this is undoubtedly a
difficult one and I mean I think I I go
back to the agent who described the the
the highways arrangements that had been
come to as a compromise and yes it is I
think to me the question is is that
compromise good enough to two way to to
outweigh the you know the benefits of of
the the affordable houses that we we
will get if if it went ahead and I'm not
quite sure that it actually does it for
me it is it is worried and I think we've
understood that the the parish the local
knowledge hasn't been engaged directly
in the
in the trying to find the solution if I
understood counsel field correctly and
so that that is that that is the
difficult balance I wouldn't say decided
which way to go but I think that's
that's the essential problem are you
know do the benefits outweigh the
disadvantages or are we taking an
existing problem that the village has
experienced for years and years already
and making it significantly worse I
think on the significantly worse site I
thought I'd picked up somewhere that the
42 dwellings was was a 25% expansion of
the village or something under whether
that doesn't seem to be in the papers
but I maybe it was an objective letter
or something it is quite a significant
expansion of a relatively small village
I'm sure thank you one of the major
attributes is cyclic is the medieval
villages that we have unfortunately
we've got modern vehicles and modern
roads and the two don't always mix I
really feel for you with your overhang
your building I think there is a risk
there
even with this footpath that increases
that risk
unfortunately near-misses not reported
if they where we might have a different
conclusion here however I can can tell
you on the crash map that I went back 10
years and there were two instance with
vehicles that the mill lane and Main
Roads ocean which had slight injuries
and it's a slight rating but that's
going back ten years I don't how far
back the highways go in the five years
there there was one actually in that
area it's been recorded and I know
there's debate about where it was but so
there have been incidents have been
accidents and it's quite likely that
there may be more and the reason for
that is this that if you're going to put
down a footpath which is shared surface
which means there is no boundary between
you in the road
you are on the road borrow line so the
situation you've got now which is
dangerous because I've walked down there
it's not ideal is pretty much the
situation you're going to have when you
put this new foot way it's pretty much
the same it's a little bit wider but
actually that contributes to another
problem a consequence the consequent
consequence is your building in the fact
that there is no minimum height sorry no
maximum height of vehicles in the UK
however they do say if whenever possible
they should be kept about 5.5 meters and
no more so they can be any size if it's
non articulated and it's a maximum
length and it's 2.5 meters wide I would
argue that coming around that bend that
caused a significant risk to the
overhanging great tool is to build it
and that to me isn't acceptable and
probable which is to keep it so so
that's a bit of an issue for me the
other thing is the is the vehicles that
move along that road we're getting
increased traffic that's that's human
human nature and it's the way we're
progressing but the agricultural
vehicles that use that road a lot and I
know this as you said could be 3 metres
wide which again causes that same
problem in that pinch point to
pedestrians because there is no physical
boundary between them and the road and
we're relying exactly what you said on
drivers having common sense and decency
unfortunately common sense isn't as
common as we'd like to think and decency
seems to be going out the window
so you can't guarantee either of those
two points therefore there is a risk to
pedestrians and I know it's not related
to the development I'll come on to that
in a moment
so I've got real concerns over road
safety and the word dangerous is you
have to quantify that I've got real
concerns I think that's as far as we'll
go on it we'll go back to the
development now the visibility displays
even though people have said they're not
happy with them they're more than that's
actually required so the development
development itself
the visibility's plays they're actually
improved safety if we're going to have a
development in that location secondly it
provides a footpath that to the perb
which is ideal and more importantly back
from the pub so that lessens the danger
for people it also connects the northern
part and the southern part if you like
at the village it joins it together
as far as the location goes I think it's
an ideal location for you
if you're going to build in a village
that's probably the place you're going
to build right slap bang in the middle
that connects the two together so as far
as the development goes I have no
concerns whatsoever and I think actually
it's a well-thought-out development and
really has made loads of compromises to
improve the well-being of the people in
the village currently such as not
building close to the Great Sea listed
building of the pub putting the lagoon
there and also thinking about the
elevations as well so well done the
developers on that unfortunately though
it keeps coming back to this highway
safety issue and I'm the guidance on
that as to how important that is to this
development approval or not because to
me it just doesn't make sense and you're
right
we can clearly see it's like the
emperor's new clothes isn't it we can
clearly see the issue we need to say
let's sort the issue out not just bypass
it for the sake of this development so
the moment I'm undecided but I am
swaying towards the refusal side based
on safety and the fact that I don't
think it's enough mitigation here to
prevent an incident or an accident or
damage to a property it's great to
listed in the future thank you I think
it's probably a good point to mention
now that if members go for a mind it to
refuse if that's the way the debate goes
I would put it to referrals but that's
just another little addition into the
pot of what we are debating so would
anybody else like to speak please pass
the war boys thank
I think I must agree with quite a great
deal of up councillor Humphries is
conserved with relation to the actual
site looking at it it does look as a
great deal of potential for actually
development on that site but as part of
this development a great deal of
emphasis was put on its sustainability
and there's two aspects of this I think
the most significant one in this respect
is its connectivity to the main part of
the village the there has been a report
on the that peak traffic which is 207
vehicles in the morning and 227 vehicles
in the afternoon they and highways did
say that this is going to be increased
by about twenty ten percent twenty six
extra vehicles at this point so that's
one quite a significant I think in fact
though they they say this would not have
a severe impact it is nevertheless I
think a significant impact and certainly
the perception from the parish council
is it is it does cause a major concern
the other is a pedestrian access it's
already quite difficult there are those
indications here of level crossings in
the opposite direction to the people
wishing to travel towards the primary
schools and the other village services
or using the footpath which though it
may be improved from my memory serves
it's quite a steep drop down onto the
main road before you get into the
village so it doesn't really encourage
people to use sustainable means of
transport use bicycles or to walk into
the village so on that aspect I think
this is quite a significant impact on
the village which doesn't make things
better it's not a positive impact
know one other aspect of sustainability
graph shows some details of the new
buildings from what I've seen of the
buildings is a minimal use of renewable
materials which actually sort of does
add to the impact on the environment
thank you thank you for that and while
you were talking there I was just made
aware and checked and looked that in the
joint local plan this particular area
has been marked as suitable for
government so just as the debate goes
forward thank you my chair I think with
that in mind in your comment earlier
that this is a serious matter I think
there are serious concerns and I think
this just need to go to referrals so how
do I do that right but I will have my
say first is I think I think the biggest
problems we have as committees is not
taking rephrase that is the highways are
our authority they are our professionals
we are not but when we are local and we
know what's happening we have to make a
decision of the path of the community
and I keep harping back to the wall pit
appeal and everybody threw their hands
up in the answer that was a private land
supply no it wasn't it was about exactly
this same issue of a narrowing of a road
and listed buildings and unfortunately
it was as it will be the case here
should it go for a refusal against
officer recommendation
and no barrister in the country that
would take it on and everybody trumpeted
and said it was the five-year land
supply that wasn't the issue it's got
exactly the same problem it's got a
narrowing of a road it's got farm
vehicles
it's got increased traffic everything
that we have here the suggestion made by
the ward member and I actually wrote it
on my bit of paper could they not put
the footpath on the other side of the
road under the overhang it seems to me
there might be other solutions that
maybe the highways can come up with it's
not up to us to do so and I'm having
difficulty with this so I will in my
capacity put this two referrals with the
good grace I hope of the committee and
the ward member and all the
representatives here so that's my
decision of the thing thank you very
much so can we have a quick break is
this was that a decision yes that's it
exactly because I can see the way the
debates going we can see what the
problems are no did we get excuse me
just a minute do I have further
questions or not yes I think madam tell
you you've noted what every member who
spoke has said and you've you're dissing
your decision was made in like that and
it seems you know that's yes so I think
John if you want any further questions
put them in writing to the officers when
it sort of moves forward thank you so if
we can have a quick break now thank you
very much indeed
you